عن الوضع معنا من مستشفى الشفاء في مدينه
غزه مراسل الجزيره اسماعيل الغول اسماعيل
ماذا عن الوضع
وجديده نعم مجمل الاوضاع منذ فجر هذا
اليوم قوات الاحتلال قصفت منزل عائله سلمي
الذي يتبع لضابط الاسعاف مؤمن سلمي مما
ادى الى استشهاد او عفوا ضابط الدفاع
المدني مؤمن سلمي الذي يعمل منذ بدايه هذه
الحرب في اجلاء المصابين واجلاء رح من
كافه الاماكن لكن قوات الاحتلال قصفت
منزله صباح هذا اليوم مما ادى الى ارتقاء
ثمانيه من افراد عائلته اخ اخ هذا الاخ
مؤمن وزوجته وسته من ابنائه جلهم من
الاطفال وفق ما شاهدنا ان جل الاطفال
للاسف هم مقطعين وقصفوا بشكل مباشر مما
ادى الى استشهاد ومسح هذه العائله بشكل
كامل من السجل المدني وا وفقد والد هذه
الاسره ورب هذه الاسره بسبب عدم وجود اي
اشلاء من اجزاء جسمه سو سوى بعض القطع من
اللحم حتى هذه اللحظه قوات الدفاع المدني
تعمل على البحث بشكل جلي عن هذا الشخص لكن
هو مفقود ثمانيه اشخاص قتلوا ب بقصف
اسرائيلي متواصل لكن مجمل الاوضاع حتى هذه
اللحظه هدوء نسبي مع استمرار القصف
المدفعي في مختلف الاماكن الجنوبيه لمدينه
غزه بالاضافه الشماليه الغربيه لمدينه غزه
هذه الاماكن التي تتواجد بها قوات
الاحتلال بكثافه لكن الحاله الانسانيه
تستمر في الصعوبه وتتزايد في حاله المجاعه
وهناك مخاطر كبيره على حياه المواطنين مما
يضطر صباح اليوم الكثير من العائلات ان
تتوجه الى منطقه الدوار الكويتي الممر
الوحيد لدخول المساعدات الانسانيه من جنوب
قطاع غزه الى شماله لكن ايضا قوات
الاحتلال صباح هذا اليوم اطلقت الرصاص على
تجمع المواطنين مما اد ادى الى وصول عدد
من الاصابات الى مستشفى الشفاء الطبي لا
نعلم حتى هذه اللحظه مجمل الاصابات التي
وقعت في ذاك المكان طواقم الاسعاف وطواقم
الدفاع المدني تعمل ايضا على اجلاء
المصابين من تلك النقطه مع استمرار القصف
المدفعي في محيط هذا التجمع تخويفا
للمواطنين لكن حاله المجاعه هي من تدفع
على الصمود في ذاك المكان لالتقاط بع
الدقيق او المعلبات التي تدخل من جنوب
قطاع غزه الى شمال قطاع غزه علما ان
محدوديه المساعدات التي تدخل هي التي
تتسبب بهذه الكارثه وندره المساعدات هي
التي تتسبب لتدافع المواطنين لاستلام
المساعدات من تلك النقطه على الرغم من
المخاطر الكبيره حتى اصبحت لقمه العيش
مغمسه بالدماء والبارود في تلك
النقطه شكرا لك من مستشفى شفاه في مدينه
غزه مراسل الجزيره اسماعيل الغول